[Music]
der
and
[Music]
a great vote and they join for the
bank and very good from highgate business
their bylaws 29 minutes kept a
vote crossing it a book tonic by
atlante
[Music]
of these with  your vote of cardboard sheets
and more
[Music]
and nothing else
this city hasn't just been cut down it's
also free also chocolate and a
high draft lion I don't know how a
combat walker on quiroga day that  I am and
act and gas from this mine has sugar
there is more
[Music]
el pastor de los pines on 33 márquez el
costs pleasure chinese club
by the time they enter I have to postpone the
planet not a trace of water from the regime they
are already stuck cutlet literally
old clothes canes  rice and beans he says it
is the quality it has come news they
write it tennis restaurant chinese food
there as a girlfriend
today
[Music]
countries
two
locations where you can load
I am definitive in warcraft management
like robert walker walke  r background
in finance it suited me [ __ ] that my
name and antonio one just like a quality
is fine nightingale and sex and bones
love active at night infinite human
longing
[Music]
this legislation is supported by
external convictions
[Music]
well
look at the  taco at the same time similar to the twist
that is a mexican version
imagine it as if it were a twist but in a
mexican version with
mentally mexican seasonings chipotle peppers
to football
[Music]
my name is zacarías galiana i am like a
taco owner right along with my
brother andrew galena
arab tacos are born out of a need
to survive
look at my grandfather this bus in 1923 24 from
the border between turkey and iraq
arriving in a strange country and trying to
survive they try to work in
whatever it takes to get ahead they see other
migrants putting a top then
Tacos Variety was founded in 1933 and that's how they
began to make the tacos that are now
known as Arab tacos.
Look at the process to make  hen the
Arab tacos is to marinate the meat, you put it on
a metal base where you start to
put it in a circular pattern, then you put onion on top
and then another layer and so it
goes layer by layer until you make the
top
[Music]
from there you take it to the machine  of
meat
that changes because it is not the same meat
many Middle Eastern people are Muslim
they cannot eat pork and here in Mexico
like fire Latin America eats little a
lot first they start selling with
corn tortillas and later they occupy
the pampita and then the people  for the psoe
not anymore but it doesn't have something that stings a little
sauce well if they thought of making a
ground chipotle sauce in a molcajete and
with that the Arab tacs can a partner
now they know it as sauce for tacuara
well all that makes it different it makes it
fusion
[Music]
then it is very interesting how
when people emigrate they carry their customs,
ideas and for years for work and for
many situations it becomes a
typical dish after a lot  time
[Music]
this effort of almost 100 years would not be
good it would not be good if it ended it already
has a history it already has a tradition it already
has a long way to go right now it's a matter
of making it known
[Music]
the first Haitians told us friends
I don't eat tortillas  I don't eat draco no
from there they kept telling each other
that food was already being sold and that this
is how they started to arrive
they tell us to read you it's a little piece
of haiti friends
[Music]
my name is blues and castle and
we cook food  and the
sweet lunch shop is here
most Haitians came to ask for
refuge in the US but it was only then that they
found bad news that they were
not allowed to spend much longer they decided to
stay here in tijuana we were
the first to make the food and it has
many  They said friends, I don't have money, I do
n't bring it, we also
gave food to the first children, they suffered a lot, they
did arrive a lot without money without clothes
because if they still steal from us or everything and po  r they
don't even bring blankets and well we gave them
blankets here right
now we make several or they make a
fist of white rice with their little
pig's hand in
leggings most of the food here is spicy because
they do eat spicy but not like
us they eat it
with reason  Well, it is very different from
ours, there is something that unites you that it is from
your land and that knows that you are going to eat
something from your country,
many times they tell us the same praise and
so that way of telling us, well, if you don't
enter feelings
and  The last ones who left came and
thanked us then he didn't
force me to be comfortable that
you leave happy with that I am well
paid
he
on the way with mothers
those enrolled don't trust me to
know him
bad it's bad it's bad  evil is
only I have given a new text
the acne
[Music]
adrián start son showing
cristman risk of interest in mexico mothers
collecting msp
in 2009
[Music]
gender evils in the interim night in
opposing displays néstor estimable
[M  úsica]
[Music]
I'm in this series
and
marta valverde clinton came in fitness to the
normal messenger sale of meat plus
others from manizales that the winemaker to
take a loft from guatemala firm in the
tank of laws
[Music]
efe
friends of his own, not even drawing for
months and a bit without converting
for hard-working illustrators at the
maitén por higuain with my mother and
coming to be more active mom was schuster
forces him to give the contribution of bulerías partners
in the last one he rapes them because it's time  of
drinking these evils are very likely
[Music]
as you know cancer work